THEY'RE HEALTHY.
>> Kenny: CROSBYBYONE.
HIS S G WIDE OT PERIOD HERD THE.
PETTERSSON O
THAT HAD A TOUGH TIME TRYING TO.
>> Kenny: YOU MENTIONED THHER.
NOW IT'S RUST DOWN TO THT WITH
CONTACT AGAINST NUMBER 71. THE
SIDE.
CROSBY CROSS ICEGOALS.STOP.
BATTERED WITH THE SHOT FROM THE
PUCK AND THE CROSSBAR, IT
APPEARS.
YEAH, CLEARLY BELOW.G
BABA GAME.
THEY HAD THEIR POWER PLA
>> Kenny: HE IS NOT THE ONLY
CATES TO SCORE FOR THE FLYER.
HOLBROOK.
GUENTZEL, NOW HAYES BACK TTH
THE PHILADELPHIA GOALSIFUL PASS
MORGAN FROST.
DOMINGUE COMES UP WITH HISUINS
FINAL IN 2017.
CENTERING PASSK TAKEN
ND POWER PLAY FOR THK OUT OF TH.
AND NOW THE OTHER.
GOOD AWARENESS BY SYDNEYV PENAL
>> Keith: HE'S DOING A
RAKELL WAITING FOR TEAMMATES OFF
THE BENCH.LOOKING FOR FARABEE.
3:3030OR THE
PENGUINS SPINNING.
WITH A SHOT.
SCORE!ROV GETTING THE
SHOT THROUGH WITH TRAFFIC.
THAT'S WHYA LOT OF LONG YEARS L
>> Ken NEXT WE.
>> Keith: YE GUARANTEE THAT WIL
MATCH-UP.
>> KennyHOGBERG GOT A STICK ON .
MALKIN IN THE FRONT.
DEFLECTED.
RIGHT THERE.H A STUF
CROSBY JUST TAKES IT CE ICE AND.
AHEAD BY HOGBERG.
NET IS
HE TIMED EVERYTHING RIGHT AND
THEN THE FLYERS S